lópez obrador ha afirmado que eeuu debe
ser corresponsable de dar solución a la
migración modificando sus políticas
migratorias porque llega esta gira justo
en este momento y es posible que de ella
salga algún tipo de acuerdo con eeuu o
precisamente los países de la región
muestran unión para forzar al vecino del
norte
si a mí me gustaría destacar dos cosas
sobre esta gira en primer lugar la
relevancia que tiene y en segundo lugar
su trascendencia es relevante porque
bueno el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador ha salido muy pocas veces de
méxico no tiene una política una buena
imagen en el caso de la política
exterior que dice que la mejor política
exterior es la política interior y
entonces no se ha involucrado mucho en
la escena internacional y ha salido tres
veces esta es la cuarta vez que salen
las otras tres veces fueron eeuu y
fueron por cuestiones de alta relevancia
como la adopción del tratado de libre
comercio la cumbre de líderes de américa
del norte y
también la presidencia de méxico del
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
entonces esta cuarta
gira que hacen en todos los años día del
mandato lleva tres años en la
presidencia es trascendental también
porque bueno recién en eeuu se lanzaron
las cívicas la oficina encargada del
control de fronteras de eeuu lanza y
hago desclasifican las estadísticas de
los cruces migratorios que están
aconteciendo en la frontera
méxico-estados unidos y vamos con el
primer trimestre de 2022 se han
disparado estás estos cruces entonces
pareciera que estos programas de emblema
que ha venido promoviendo méxico no
están dando los resultados esperados y
bueno esa es la intención de ir a
centroamérica
por tanto no hay ningún acuerdo previo
con eeuu se podría llegar a un acuerdo
junto a los países centroamericanos
después de esta gira
si el problema es que eeuu ha
cuestionado los programas de
transferencia de efectivo como son el
programa sembrando vidas y el programa
jóvenes construyendo el futuro que son
los programas que implementa méxico a
través de sus agencias en estos países
de américa este de américa santa no se
ha cuestionado a partir sé que no son
transparentes que no ofrecen resultados
y que bueno hay poca retroalimentación
política entonces mientras no hay un
acuerdo en cómo implementar estos
programas tampoco va a haber
financiamiento por parte del gobierno
estadounidense el gobierno estadunidense
lo que está haciendo es financiar
programas propios a través de ustream
entonces tenemos dos estrategias la
estadounidense y la mexicana para tener
un mismo problema que son las causas
profundas de la migración proveniente
del triángulo norte de centroamérica